[Music]
tensions remain high in the black sea
after a confrontation last month between
a british warship and the russian
military russian planes
buzzed the british destroyer and issued
hostile warnings
all of it happened in the same region
where the u.s and dozens of countries
are now holding military exercises
russia recently threatened to bomb
foreign warships that pass through what
it considers to be
its territorial waters off of crimea
an american destroyer the uss ross
departed the port of odessa to lead
those military drills
and holly williams is the only u.s
network correspondent on board
we're sailing about 5 000 miles away
from the east coast of the u.s
but as america's relationship with
russia has deteriorated
the black sea which is russia's backyard
has become
a potential flashpoint
u.s sailors opened fire on a hostile
craft
took aim at enemy warplanes and came
under attack from
fighter jets but this was just a
simulation
a live fire military exercise
with 28 u.s allies
yet america's real-life rival appeared
to be keeping
careful watch four russian ships took it
in turns to shadow the uss
ross russian fighter jets repeatedly
circled nearby
commander john d john is a 20-year
veteran of the navy great work
and told us he wasn't concerned it would
take much more than this to provoke a
clash
if somebody opened fire on you then that
would uh warrant
you taking self-defense measures if
somebody is aggressive
then and you feel threatened then you
have the right to defend yourself
[Music]
last month a british naval ship the hms
defender
was subjected to more hostile tactics in
the black sea
the uk government denied russia's claims
that it dropped bombs in the british
ship's path
and fired warning shots but the russian
military did
threaten to attack if you don't change
the course i'll be fired
as tensions between the us and russia
have ratcheted up
the black sea region has become the
scene of confrontations
russia sent soldiers to illegally seize
control of the crimean peninsula
from neighboring ukraine in 2014 and
russia claims the british ship was
sailing in what are now its territorial
waters
the us and its allies don't recognize
that
russia's threatened to bomb foreign
warships that sail into those waters in
future
the training exercise was several miles
away and the uss ross is
heavily armed with tomahawk and harpoon
missiles
and torpedoes commander john calls it
the swiss army knife of us
warships you can hit a plane you can hit
an enemy submarine you can hit an enemy
destroyer
that's exactly all of that that's
exactly right during this exercise the
u.s navy
used that might to reassure its allies
the message that it sends is that
international
airspace international water space is
for everybody it doesn't belong to one
country the u.s says it's committed to
maintaining security in the black sea
and that's crucial for america's friends
in this region many of them countries
living in close proximity to russia
and fearing russian encroachment for cbs
this morning holly williams
on board the uss ross